nächste quizfrage was ist grün und
stinkt nach erfolg richtig die grünen
liebe zuschauer gestern in deutschland
trend sogar vor der union das ist
wahnsinn willkommen in der neuen öko
republik deutschland
vielleicht auch weil wir deutschen uns
immer nur auf ein thema gleichzeitig
konzentrieren können und jetzt ist es
offensichtlich klima die grünen
jedenfalls kommen aus dem feiern gar
nicht mehr raus
die bilder von der europawahl partie dem
moment wo der erste grüne beiden kommt
motto hier fliegen gleich die löcher aus
dem tofu
sogar ein eisbär feiertag ist er ja
den kennen sie den eisbären oder und das
kein wunder dass wir den kennen da hat
ja zuletzt auch in fast allen grünen
wahlspots mitgespielt
allerdings ist in der rom haben wir
festgestellt leider zu kopf gestiegen
seit der wahlparty ist der ja muss man
sagen total abgestürzt pöbelt auf der
straße wildfremde leute
wer trotz voll mit seinem suv durch die
gegend und lässt sich dann in einer
spielstraße blitzen es ist traurig mal
traurig
huber hysky
im kontrast dazu stets bescheiden bleibt
dagegen unser kommender kanzler der
robot wenn ich den stern titel hier
richtig verstanden habe robert habeck
müssen wir sagen kann ja nichts dafür
aber die meisten interviews mit ihm sind
im moment wirklich keine journalistische
sternstunde
neulich in der bams waren das hier
ernsthaft die ersten beiden fragen an
den mann die erst aber wie lange
brauchen sie morgens im bad für ihre
haare
das hat mich noch nie einer gefragt dann
verwurzelte frisur öfter mal ein t shirt
ist dieses ziel auch eine politische
botschaft und später noch wann haben sie
zuletzt geweint ja ich habe das letzte
mal geweint dass ich das interview
gelesen habe viel besser lief es beim
talk mit der zeitschrift brigitte
da haben sie ihn wenigstens voll
kritisch nach seinen vorbildern gefragt
ich glaube die erste figur die mich
tatsächlich geprägt hat ist der fuchs in
dem disney film von hollywood
ich will nicht klugscheißern aber der
fuchs in dem robin hood film ist robin
hood
man will ich eine ja eine art
hofberichterstattung wohl habeck noch
gar kein kanzler ist aber entscheidende
frage wie lange hält dieser grüne hype
wie lange ja meistens meistens beginnt
die entzauberung ja schon mit
sondierungsgesprächen
und auch wenn kompromisse natürlich zur
demokratie dazu gehören bei den jamaika
verhandlungen waren die grünen schon
sehr flexibel am unter anderem direkt
auf ein ausstiegsdatum für den
verbrennungsmotor verzichtet die partei
ist halt einen weiten weg gegangen
seit ihrer frühen wahlspots damals in
den achtzigern
wir wollen politische alternativen
aufzeigen
das sind noch menschen wie du und ich
annegret sie haben richtig gesehen ja
das war tatsächlich die junge annegret
kramp karrenbauer die unter havag wohl
demnächst vize kanzlerin wird wenn alles
nach plan läuft ja denn anders als in
bremen halten sich die grünen im bund ja
noch alle optionen offen klar man könnte
kritisch nachfragen wie viel sinn macht
eine koalition mit einer cdu deren
landwirtschaftsministerin gerade wieder
18 pflanzenschutzmittel inklusive
glyphosat zugelassen hat aber das sind
details und auch die union hat natürlich
junge frische umweltpolitiker in ihren
reihen
wenn man dann auch zeitpunkt ist jetzt
ein beispielsweise im jahr 2020 das ziel
zu haben dass die neuzulassungen von
autos dann immer mit grünen motoren geht
wer ist schon ein ehrgeiziges ziel aber
es ist zu erreichen
absolut ja das glaube ich auch heute
zwölf jahre und 30 kilo später gehört
gehört markus söder auch zu denen die
bei bedarf gerne das schreckenszenario
vom grünen deutschland an die wand malen
wurde jetzt sogar verfilmt 2021 das jahr
in dem die grünen an die macht kommen
drei minuten später stellen uns die ökos
den strom deutsche trauen sich nicht
mehr aus ihrem autos weil sie draußen
zusammengeschlagen werden von einer
grünen fahrrad es hinter 812 schuften
unter tage in solar bergwerken um
ökostrom abzubauen
und heterosexuelle männer müssen bei der
gender polizei ab sofort ihren penis
abgeben
sehen sie den geilen typ aus der werbung
als robert habeck veronica ferres als
kaputtes hinterrad und in der rolle der
greta thunberg anton hofreiter 2025
ja
der höhenflug der grünen ein echter
wendepunkt oder doch nur vorübergehende
modeerscheinung reden wir drüber mit
wörter hausten geschiedene knalligen
dingeldey von dem kreuzberger grünen
frau dörte wie beurteilen sie denn den
aktuellen grünen heim
also ganz ehrlich oliver mich
kostenstreit regelrecht an
ja jetzt ist es auf immer cool grün zu
sein
ich bin meine ganze schulzeit über
beschimpft worden als bürge mücke oder
jute unternehmer axel hatte ich damals
mehr als ja auf dem ganzen kopf
heute trägt dreadlocks prinzip schon
höre man ruhiger langweilig uncool war
ja und mein idol war auch nicht so eine
niedliche berbalk sondern die knie
[Musik]
wer so ab dance theater ist mit sich auf
jeden fall im rhein
also wie gesagt deutschland wird grüner
lache mich tot hier aktuelle zahlen
oliver 71 prozent der deutschen haben
eine umweltbewusste einstellung aber nur
28 leben danach
jetzt gerade wird zum beispiel wieder
alle gegrillt wird nicht bei drei auf
dem baum ist und am liebsten frisst der
deutsche schwein obwohl nur ein prozent
der armen viecher artgerecht gehalten
werden um verstehen nur ein prozent gut
so gesehen kann man ja eigentlich gar
kein schnitzelbrötchen mehr essen also
so lecker das ist zwischendurch aber man
kann man nicht haben
also die meisten sauer werden immer noch
in so janz winzigen kästen fixiert die
können sich da drinnen nicht mal
umdrehungen ich würde ja gut wenn man
das weiß dann sollte man natürlich als
denkender menschen das ist klar
mit einem funken anstand
logisch ja das ist eine katastrophe ich
meine allein in deutschland werden jedes
jahr 2,8 milliarden ein weg geschaffen
nutzt jetzt sind unfassbare 320.000 pro
stunde das ist ja also manche leute und
ich und ich dachte bei uns hat ein
bewusstseinswandel stattgefunden ja na
klar eine art juni sind für alle ganz
weit vorn also ich bin eigentlich der
fleischesser heute normal salat reis
heiße sind weiße einmal in der woche
doch einmal angebracht ist aber dann
auch gerne mit fleisch oder wurst
vegetarisch die zahl der flugreisen ja
die nimmt ständig zu und gegen das
schlechte gewissen wenn jetzt alle in
supermarkt und fressen diese neuen
fleischlosen bürger aus den usa und die
säulen richtig lecker sein neckar macht
überhaupt keinen sinn vegetarisches
essen lecker schmeckt ich habe jahrelang
nur q4 fressen und jetzt kommen die
plötzlich mit sachen wie schmecken
lassen
wieso das ist doch gut wenn jetzt noch
mehr menschen bürger ja
der ort ist schaffte dinkel schritte ab
montag im handel
was oft ist hier trocknet da seetang auf
altem dinkel brötchen 500.000 stück habe
ich unter der achsel ihr wollt nicht
allein auf messen mit truppen die
scheiße alkohol gehörte ausgeschieden
michael b schreibt auf facebook wilke du
bist der letzte arsch nur große fresse
ich möchte ich mal sehen wenn es hart
auf hart kommt dann schaust du dir in
die hose warte ab ein sprichwort sagt
man trifft sich immer zweimal im leben
mach weiter so mit einer großen fresse
wie können warten
sehr geehrter herr b man sieht sich im
leben nicht nur zweimal sondern jeden
freitag um 22.30 in zwei oder hier auf
youtube wenn sie uns abonnieren